>> Dana: PROGRESSIVE CRIME
POLICIES UNDER FIRE AGAIN,
SHOCKING VIDEO SHOWS A BRAZING
CARJACKING IN NEW YORK WHERE THE
CLERK JUMPED ON TOP OF A
MINIVAN, PUMMELING THE
53-YEAR-OLD DRIVER IN THE VICTIM
WAS TREATED FOR A FRACTURED EYE
SOCKET AND IN OREGON THEY ARE
CRITIQUING -- FOR GRANTING
CLEMENCY TO A COLD-BLOODED
MURDERER.
SHE DEFENDED HER ACTIONS BY
SAYING THE MURDERER WAS ONLY 17
WHEN HE COMMITTED THE CRIME.
ON THAT POINT WHAT ABOUT THE
DECISION TO NOT CHARGE SOMEBODY
AS AN ADULT AT 17?
>> Judge Jeanine: FIRST OF
ALL, KATE BROWN, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU REMEMBER BUT SHE IS THE ONE,
RIGHT BEFORE THANKSGIVING WHEN
SHE DECIDED THERE SHOULD ONLY BE
SIX PEOPLE FOR THANKSGIVING, AT
YOUR THANKSGIVING DINNER TABLE
AND IF YOUR NEIGHBOR, IF YOU SEE
THAT YOUR NEIGHBOR HAS MORE THAN
SIX, CALL THE AUTHORITIES.
SHE IS A LITTLE WACKY AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED.
WHAT IF YOU HAVE SEVEN KIDS?
TELL THE OTHER ONES TO HIT THE
ROAD?
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE FACT
THAT THIS WOMAN WOULD DECIDE TO
LET OUT A CONVICTED MURDERER WHO
WAS CONVICTED NOT JUST OF MURDER
BUT MURDER FOR HIRE AND
UNDERSTAND THERE'S DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF MURDER.
A MURDER TO HIRE, TO SILENCE A
WITNESS, THIS IS MURDER TO
SILENCE A WITNESS.
THEY ARE PARTICULARLY HEINOUS,
FOR WHICH YOU CAN IN SOME STATES
GET THE DEATH PENALTY.
SHE DECIDES WITHOUT EVEN
CONTACTING THE FAMILY OF THE
VICTIM, IT WAS A 17-YEAR-OLD
GIRL WHO KNEW ABOUT THIS
DIRTBAG, AND HE WAS A DIRTBAG.
HE DID A WHOLE SPREE OF
BURGLARIES AND SHE KNEW ABOUT IT
AND HE WANTED TO SILENCE HER
INTO IT BY SHOOTING HER IN THE
BACK OF THE HEAD.
KATE BROWN IS AN IMBECILE.
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
JURIES GO THROUGH BEFORE THEY
CONVICTED BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT.
ALL OF THESE MID-LEVEL AND
HIGHEST LEVEL, THE JUDGE MAKES
THE SENTENCE AND THE CORRECTIONS
AND I THINK IS JUST EROSION OF
FAITH IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, IT TELLS VICTIMS
FAMILIES DON'T COME FORWARD,
DON'T TESTIFY BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO LET THEM OUT AND IT
TELLS PEOPLE THAT WE ARE SOFT ON
CRIME.
AND YOU KNOW, WE ASK THAT.
IT'S ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS
AS A D.A., ASSISTANT D.A. TO GET
PEOPLE TO COOPERATE AND TESTIFY.
WHY SHOULD THEY COOPERATE?
IF THAT GUY'S GOING TO BE OUT ON
THE STREET?
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THIS CASE?
>> AND REAL QUICK, HE SHOULD
MOVE IN TO KATE BROWN.
SHE SHOULD TAKE THE GUY IN.
THEY ALWAYS MENTION THE AGE OF
THE SUSPECT, THEY NEVER EVER
MENTION THE AGE OF THE VICTIM,
THAT DRIVES ME CRAZY.
DOES TELL EVERYBODY WHEN THE
SENTENCES ARE GIVEN THEY COULD
CHANGE AT ANY TIME.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY FLUID.
I SERVE A LIFE SENTENCE WITHOUT
PAROLE FOR MURDER BUT I IDENTIFY
AS A NONVIOLENT FELON, WHY NOT?
THIS IS WHY THE FLORIDA SHERIFF,
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY, WAS
RIGHT WHEN HE SAID TO SHOOT
INTRUDERS DEAD WHEN THEY HOME
INVADE BECAUSE THAT IS THE ONLY
FOOLPROOF PREVENTION OF
RECIDIVISM.
AND IF YOU THINK THEY MIGHT LET
THEM OUT, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
SHOOT HIM DEAD.
>> Dana: THE CARJACKING, THIS
IS HAPPENING A LOT.
>> Jessica: AND ON VIDEO,
REMEMBER, WHEN SOMEONE WAS
MAKING A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
WITNESS TO THE CARJACKING BEHIND
HIM AND MADE THE CALL HIMSELF TO
REPORT IT?
WHAT I AM OVERWHELMED BY IS THE
SHOCKING LACK OF HUMANITY
PERMEATING THROUGH EVERY LEVEL
OF SOCIETY AND THIS COMING OFF
OF A TIME WHEN I FELT LIKE WE
WERE UNITED.
CERTAINLY IN THE EARLY DAYS OF
THE PANDEMIC WHERE PEOPLE WERE
SCARED, THEY WERE CONSCIOUS OF
THEIR ELDERLY NEIGHBORS,
EVERYONE WANTED TO PROTECT THOSE
IN THEIR LIFE THAT THEY NEEDED
TO, AND IT OBVIOUSLY HAS
ELECTORAL IMPLICATIONS, BUT
THOSE ARE SO SMALL IN THE
CONTEXT OF JUST HOW YOU TREAT
PEOPLE WHEN YOU ARE WALKING DOWN
THE STREET.
>> Dana: YOU HADN'T BEEN TO
NEW YORK IN A WHILE, HAVE YOU
NOTICED ANY DIFFERENCE HERE?
IS THERE AN INCREASED ANXIETY
ABOUT CRIME?
>> Jason: IT DOES NOT FEEL THE
SAME SAFETY, EVEN IN THE
TIMES SQUARE AREA THERE USED TO
BE.
HE COULD WALK ALL ACROSS THE
CITY.
>> Dana: I AGREE.
>> Jason: RESPECTED YOUR
REASON I THINK THERE IS GREAT
RESPECT THERE BUT YOU ALSO HAVE
TO PROSECUTE THESE PEOPLE AND IF
YO